t-minus ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one and liftoff the
Falcon soars from its perch toward the
International Space Station carrying
dragon and new science for the one-year
crew
thirty seconds into plate all systems
are go for the Falcon 9
and one minute into play
standing by for the Falcon that goes
supersonic one minute ten seconds after
liftoff
and the Falcon 9 is
Falcons now pass through the maximum
dynamic pressure max Q the next major
milestone first stage engines shut down
about two minutes and 38 seconds into
flight
and Becca's jillion T plus two minutes
altitude 32 kilometers of the speed 1
o'clock kilometer per second downrange
distance 13.5 kilometers from first
stage engine cutoff
standing by for main engine cutoff
it's true one Mikko separation confirmed
good luck everyone
see these stages separating and we have
recognition standing by the single
Merlin vacuum engine ignited the stage
altitude 86 kilometers per second
downrange distance 63 kilometers
standing by in 15 seconds for the
dragon's protective nose cone to
jettison
three minutes 50 seconds into the flight
of Falcon carrying the Dragon spacecraft
toward rendezvous with the International
Space Station on Friday morning h2
propulsion still nominal
which one's those teeth Harvester
nominal sallekhana Sherlock on both
stages acquisition of signal bring a
diagnostician
we have stage one booze back startup
four minutes 40 seconds into flight the
spacex second stage engine continues to
perform normally taking the Falcon 9 and
dragon away from the limb of the earth B
plus five minutes
altitude 165 kilometers speed two point
five six kilometers per second downrange
distance 221 kilometers vehicles
following the nominal we had Stage one
who's back shut down
five minutes 30 seconds mission elapsed
time everything remains normal about
four minutes the new propulsion is still
nominal about four minutes from the
second stage engine cutoff New Hampshire
acquisition a signal now processing the
signal through a New Hampshire tracking
site six minutes into the flight